um and you know who's partly to blame
for this is rogan now this is a little
clip that somebody put up
when joe rogan got way too high remember
this is the intellectual guy this is the
guy who has all the thinkers of the
world on
you know it's people that like like real
they'll play something for you like
they'll play the beatles
like lucy in the sky with diamonds you
put on some headphones
and listen to loose smoke a joint put on
some headphones
and listen to a song
that was created by mouth too he's got
the first
wave of british superstars look okay
first off everybody had an older cousin
who smoked weed and this is what joe
rogan is in this i haven't been this
high i know i
don't think i've ever been maybe the
first time i got high was the
the last time i was this high now there
have been times in my adult like where
you get the right combo of stuff and
you're like
you get good good wax or something and
take it but it's been
a really but no i mean you'd have to
have wax and edibles it would have to be
one of those weird things yeah but
where you're like at a hotel with like
out of town on something and you've read
the rest of the night off and you're
like
gobble gobble and wax and you're like
october's my favorite too because for
the last three years rogan has done or
this will be the third year he does that
sober october where he actually doesn't
do weed or anything or drink
he is so cranky and so angry and he's
watch mark my words you guys are gonna
be sending me clips now in october when
through the sober october pink trip is
going to be a busy boy
would you stop harassing me jamie and
he's going to be like
just clipping it up why is the clipping
so ah
jamie stop clicking your mouse so loud
and just yeah he is a grump i'm gonna
say hand
cut hey jamie did we actually cut this
time unlike when we did literally
the most important show we ever did also
jamie you need to uproot your life
because we are moving to idaho and that
means you got to come with me what are
you going to work on honestly
with red band i want to see the joe
rogan silver october he just snaps like
bill o'reilly
[ __ ] thing sucks yeah he is a grumpy
goose i'm going to say it i'll be the
first listen pardon my language youtube
but i'm going to say i don't care if you
ban me
he's a grumpy goose in october
they came to america and they're on acid
and they're saying about lucy
in the sky with diamonds and it's it's
amazing it's
what
you do you understand right if i met
like before i said hey like uh
what a party or i got some friends
coming here to meet this friend of mine
he's a cool dude right
and you introduced me to somebody and
that was what they were talking about
later on
but within minutes i would go up to
royce and go i [ __ ] hate this guy
this guy i hate this person i don't know
terrible i hate him i hate everything
about this person
superstars that came to america
and they're on acid and they're saying
about lucy in the sky with diamonds
and it's it's it's amazing
it's amazing that's amazing you said a
whole truckload of words
and none of it made any sense
do that who's the guest by the way
notice this is 58 minutes of nobody
talking to him it just cuts to brian
callan like
cool can i promote my amazon special
that i had to do on amazon because
brennan made me
did you see that go back i did you see
that
hold on it's even longer than that let
me start here do that
right now six seconds dude that's more
than we
six seconds that's that's more than weed
you think a little too much kombucha
that's not weed i'm telling you man that
if maybe too much alpha brain if this if
you told me maybe this was coming right
off sober october maybe
because if i quit weed for a month and
then i got stoned
i'd be like that or that was or it means
i'd be on something else
that was dude that that's me honestly
like
back when i was doing percocets a lot
back when i was trying to be a little
wannabe mac miller um
dead well i didn't want to really be
dead
if when i got up to like two three and
i'm finally like three
four percocet a day i could see
tail end of the day me at home being a
little like
still fine but like just having a
conversation and being like
you know like think about that
you know you like like write the second
thing about it yeah
think about what i forgot let's hear
that quiet again i gotta hear one more
it's really funny
do that
[Laughter]
right now do you want us to do it right
now
just think i want to think about this
for a second
just imagine he just wants to play with
in his imagination while he's live
you're doing a show joe joe joe come
back to reality
millions of people she's your millions
of people are watching it's your job
if i were this high and this checked out
during
one episode of the show i would have to
hear it from him the rest of the day
yes yes if i was just like
like are you gonna do anything or what
are you doing apparently rogan and
duncan admitted that they were on
shrooms in this podcast
that makes sense makes sense that
absolutely makes sense
and i mean do what you want i guess
i don't care but if we were doing
shrooms
on youtube we would get a strike like
you know what i mean and i'm not saying
i don't want joe gonna get a strike i
don't care give a [ __ ] right
but you're putting out a product right
you have advertisers right
and can you imagine if tomorrow tucker
showed up on acid
like that would be a big deal you know
what i mean what if tucker's been taking
acid this whole time and that's why he's
just so woke he's
[ __ ] waking up she's been taking acid
ever since he started getting his trust
fund money
opening up that third eye yeah it's so
apparently somebody says shrooms uh and
you know even still though
i've done shrooms and i don't get like
that
and by the way i get giggly mark s says
it makes for boring radio
it can make for good radio remember
years ago we had somebody take shrooms
oh yeah
and but i didn't take trump you need
people that are sober
and then we competed in trivia right i
lost and that was funny
like that was a funny bit because i lost
contribute to a guy who's out of his
mind on shrooms
but one guy was out of his mind on
trooms and it was like
a peripheral person it wasn't neither
none of the main hosts
it's not like everybody ate shrooms and
then well let's just [ __ ] it dude
it was we all right as a goof we're
gonna put this one guy on a shitload of
mushrooms
and then i'm gonna see if i can beat him
uh in trivia
yeah i so anyways he's the think by the
way for the whole weed culture
thing la is a cesspool man i would never
i would
even the people that live there like
rogan's trying to move out ben shapiro's
been talking about moving to texas too
there's
they make their [ __ ] they make their
nut there right and then they're like ah
but i gotta leave this this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] but then they
bring the parasites with them exactly
that's how you get cities like houston
that are turning into like
these liberal cesspools and places
you're not that you would you go and you
move into a place that has bed bugs and
then you want to come back here and
bring bed bugs with you yeah no keep
your bed bugs in la like
go over there and the problem rogan is
big enough to wherever he moves people
will fly to be on rogan like people yeah
i guess i'll fly to boise
you know maybe flights to boise will get
cheaper that's about the only upset i
could think
i think he was talking about idaho or
colorado i'm going to lean towards
colorado colorado makes more sense
for him because that's still kind of a
more hippier place where he could still
live in the mountains and smoke his weed
and shoot elk with both
and shoot out yeah with bose and by the
way from what i've heard because he does
a lot of these bow hunting shows or
whatever he's really bad at it
like you know obviously compared to me
and you he's probably a [ __ ]
way better [ __ ] but other people that
actually do it are like yeah
he sucks like there's shows you could
watch him on hunting doesn't catch
anything like he's terrible at it
i think so i think the uh the red bar
people are trying to start a rumor that
uh
he buys all his meats that he shows on
instagram from like omaha steaks
like everybody's trying to get the rumor
going that he doesn't actually he's not
good at bow hunting and he's never
killed an elk and none of that's his
meat
because he's always like oh we're eating
some elk steaks and then you can always
see comments now that's omaha
it's a known fact in the comedy
community that joe rogan pisces
from omaha stakes and then lies yeah joe
rogers dude is an alpha in l.a but if
you were to move to like another play in
the midwest
he'd be a phobia get get out of here
you're not a real hunter rogan [ __ ]
shut up
nobody with a lot of money is a real
hunter no no
you know what's a really good point
nobody with money and you go on a safari
with a jeep and a shotgun and kill a
lion that's not really
gangster as [ __ ] is you know like
there's legit africans that are still
like carving a spear together and being
like i'm gonna go get this [ __ ] tiger
today or we'll die yeah that's a [ __ ]
hunter
yeah or we're gonna die uh jake five
dollars we're the dudes that do the the
pull bows
those are hot uh yeah i'll accept the
people that do the actual pull balls
because those are [ __ ]
those are hard